el área superficial de un cubo es igual
a la suma de las áreas de sus seis caras
veamos esto siempre es bueno visualizar
las cosas si este es el cubo si este es
el cubo podemos ver tres caras tres
caras son las que estamos viendo de
frente pero si fuera transparente
podríamos ver que de hecho son seis
caras las del cubo una dos tres caras el
frente está en la parte de abajo está en
la parte de atrás y está también en la
parte de atrás
en efecto el cubo tiene seis caras el
área superficial de un cubo cuya arista
mide x este de aquí es x está de aquí es
x y está aquí es x está dada por la
expresión 6x cuadrada
si se verifica cada cara tiene una área
de x x x x cuadrada y si son 6 caras el
área superficial es 6 x cuadrada julia
tiene dos recipientes de forma cúbica
que quiere pintar un cubo tiene aristas
de longitud 2 uno de los cubos tiene
aristas que miden dos vamos a dibujarlo
aquí este es un cubo cuyas aristas miden
y dos y el otro cubo tiene aristas que
miden 1.5 vamos a hacerlo por acá un
poco más pequeño este es el otro cubo
cuyas aristas miden 1.5 1.5 y 1.5 aquí
cuál es el área superficial total que
ella tiene que pintar bueno sabemos que
el área superficial de cada cubo va a
ser 6 x x cuadrada donde x es la
longitud de la arista del cubo entonces
para este cubo el área superficial va a
ser igual a 6 que multiplica déjame
escribirlo con el mismo color del cubo 6
que multiplica a la longitud de la
arista del cubo las dimensiones del cubo
ancho largo y alto son las mismas la
longitud de la arista si es que sería 6
por la longitud de la arista que es x
elevado al cuadrado 6 por 2 al cuadrado
y para el cubo más chico el área
superficial va a ser 6 por la longitud
de la arista que en este caso es 1.5
elevado al cuadrado y si queremos el
área superficial que ella va a pintar
la suma de estas dos áreas así es que
tenemos que sumar estos dos términos
calculemos esto entonces esto es 6 por 2
al cuadrado 6 por 4 24
+ 6 por 1.5 al cuadrado
dejamos 15 al cuadrado es 225 así es que
1.5 al cuadrado es 2.25 así es que 1.5
al cuadrado es 2.25 y 6 por 2.25 no no
es tan fácil directamente hagámoslo por
acá sería 2.25 que multiplica 6 tenemos
entonces 6 por 5 30 llevamos 36 por 22
12 y 315 llevamos 16 por 2 12 y 113 y el
punto decimal que lo corremos los
lugares 13.5 así es que esto es mas 13.5
hacemos la suma de estas dos cantidades
24 más 13.5 esto es igual al área
superficial total que tiene que pintar
que es 37.5 y esta área estaría en las
unidades no no nos dan unidades así es
que sería simplemente 37.5 unidades
cuadradas